yeah yeah Monday Monday Monday
it's Monday you ate a calzone a little
cuz oh I'm also better off your [ __ ] oh
yeah you know what on the same way
yesterday my tribe name [ __ ] I'm not
gonna drink coffee yeah because it
doesn't mess with you it a little bit it
does I decided well I want to be part of
the cuz I had AIDS from it yeah I wanted
to be sick too like it sometimes you
just wanna borrow the club yeah
sometimes you want to have acidic
properties you ever want braces or
glasses cuz your other friends had him
you know but I faked like that bad very
common I think like I had bad vision
my brother had horrible vision like
horrible vision he looked like to get
off the Sandlot and the one that goes
for a burn and so we went to
LensCrafters and I was a can those are
cool glasses cause like you so I was
like what's that say my dad's like you
can't really so then they they brought
me in the back and I think like got read
and he's like what's that lowest one say
and I was like L acts and then I'd like
mess up the last two he's like he can
definitely see he's making this up I
just want him cuz they was I don't know
my boy years you wanted to be so slow
man you want to be my brother Adam I did
would would do weirder things like that
I would go I'm I would like decide that
my name was Alex because I think you're
insane yep so you tell friends you do
didn't people like me my name is Alex I
wanted to be Alex for the day what a
[ __ ] weirdo but I was young I was
like thirty when'd you first start lying
about your age I never have lied about
my age actually
you've never even you're like 40 you
look younger you know I'm saying yeah I
never did because maybe cuz of Google
but I never did it I did it like the
like just a few months ago not like I
just caught myself some girls a calorie
I was like 31 no and I went in my brain
I went oh wow no you know what I just
lied about my age
yeah she's just gonna go home and if she
wants me up he's definitely see Brenna's
easy or III don't mean to talk about
this but Steve Rannazzisi was talking
about that like when he got you know he
would talked about being in the towers
right to sit them but he said he goes he
kind of said it to a guy that he didn't
know he was new and he was standing
there and a guy goes bro he was in the
towers and he wasn't and and and he was
like
he goes I have a why of five seconds
right now just tell this guy no then
they were all like oh really and then he
was like yeah and then all of a sudden
became the tower guy but he was like now
if I tell him I'm lying they're gonna
think I'm the biggest weirdo and I just
want to make friends I'm here at the
college during the whole thing so he
kind of like goes like all right and
then from then on he became the guy in
the town yeah yeah yeah and then he had
to live that forever sometimes when I
say something whether it's on a podcast
or we're on stage like there's there's a
little thing in my head that goes ain't
like me and I don't know you're gonna
get in trouble from me and Rogan I'm
like yep me and from him Hogan what I
remember a long time ago I remember
since we always made a pact we were like
never lie to each other never lie to
your friends like you know we can do we
can do White Lies right but but don't
lie like straight up lie well sometimes
you can't be friends no he said he said
Sam here but I'm actually there but he
said something to me it would be the
equivalent of I camera what it was but
he said something he goes I was there or
something and then and then there was a
pause ago yeah and I started talking to
us or I wasn't or I just do that do and
I understood exactly why he said yeah we
did it do you know what I mean you know
say you'll just say something like um
what the [ __ ] was I I almost lied about
something the other day that way where I
was like I wanted to be there because I
would tell I was important for the my
argument and I go I was there dude
oh I know it was one I ever met Alan day
just like yesterday so so I'm to my
neighbors
I gotta slide they're not your friends
we're in the car and my they go I'm they
go yeah but with Stevie with Stevie blue
eyes really was he really in jail
already make that up and he goes I go
not only was he in jail you go over the
top I know for a fact you ran with guys
because when we were in Boston I met the
guys who went to jail at then I go and
by the way and this is a story that he
was pretty was misread Carlo I shouldn't
say anyway he's waited with his buddy
well Steve eternal Stevie was with his
friend Jason and they were going down
the stairs of a strip club and the
bouncer camera now goes you can't go
down there - his assistant was with us
because he had beef with this other
mafia guy
some other guy down there another they
had to leave so I go we were walking
down we were walking down the stairs and
the guy came out of told us we had to
leave I put myself in the story you're
trying to validate your point for those
sure wise leave you sure was and by the
way your neighbors though yep
lied to him yeah but they lied to him in
the car I just realized that I total
armless lie wanted then you want that
validation why don't you know what for
your case
I was pretty nice my case we can't you
you know you're being a lawyer really
yet I'm fair Stevie and I'm his lawyer
they didn't give my friend respect for
doing time in jail sometimes it
frustrate ya so you matter I can't stand
what I tell sterling those Nam like what
what I feel like getting out documents
like not [ __ ] look boom boom boom
now I told you we've had I've had
friends who will tell a story about
being there and it's someone else's
story yeah and that person's there that
guy goes yeah something like me I'm
forgive me I'd be like you're crazy so
I'm gonna let you tell that story and I
don't want to embarrass you but you have
those friends who were like hey man
[ __ ] that's nice yeah I would 100%
call you gotta be run yep like
definitely not that's my story sight
definitely you uh now I've been catching
a little heat for me and Chris online
for my fanny pack yeah man um hold on I
woke up however sitting on Sombra before
you hate on me did you like the fanny
pack do you get why another man wear
fanny pack and I'm not from France no
what did they make sense though nice
empty I'm being dead serious you don't
you don't show up you don't wear that
big fanny pack you don't wear it around
the house but around speak don't stir
mouth don't speak you don't worry around
the house you can never take a picture
with it it's Gucci as well I find it
very offensive it's not cheap and I and
I'm gonna say this and I said this on
your Instagram foot and I really miss
you I love you I know you're a very
strong guy I know you're a [ __ ] I
know you'll beat the [ __ ] out of me I
swear to God and I swear to god I'll
fight you and I'll fight you with
everything I have and I'll tag you right
in your [ __ ] you know it's bears yeah
because you're gonna go he won't hit me
and I'm gonna connect him to sit down on
my punches and you know I've been
working on it
spearmint okay how can I say this yeah
that's not my fan in Petach okay I was
at the mall yesterday and Sophie City
walking around it's not yours
it's no it's Joe's so I guess I I
haven't known how to even broach the
subject I know it's tough
that's your girl's eye tough yes so is
Joe's but I didn't notice we walk around
tiger and she had like a switch around
her waist and she takes off in a month
nobody's ad she goes what do you mean I
go where'd that come from
she's even shopping for a guy like new
where'd that come from Sheila I got the
other day she does like this Tracy thing
where they trade stuff and yeah I know
got a fanny pack she was it is I went oh
my god and I started laughing that is a
glorious I said that's hilarious and she
goes okay I go I take a picture to piss
off everybody I know she goes no you
can't take pictures it's not gonna fit
you like I'll make it fit give me that
thing she gives it to me I take a
picture and I just posted it for you
Rogan delete just for the pure hey
tastic I you take from my brother just
says what the [ __ ] when Tony sends me a
text goes hey man this is worse than
that time yet silver here you okay like
dead sits I love it fantastic trolling
yes sometimes your frame makes sense
well I work out with a fanny pack like
an athletic fanny pack it's like small
sleek it's like water resistance I've
hurt my phone in there so pepper no so I
just put around my way so when I run you
have to worry about it sure it's dope I
put they make sense though I pick things
over just to the side like think about
all your stuff in the house man okay I
put it over the side I'm wearing on my
belt
you like accoutrement you like having
little things facts makes sense I'll say
this the only two people I know that
rock fanny packs to give to for [ __ ] or
anyone think so Joe Rogan who sells a
fanny pack then quranic very wet and
Mirko Cro Cop those who've got a pack
all the time really
you go tell them to their face that not
to wear if any better go bloke with that
yeah he gets away with it yeah anyways
it he also has like I had one when I was
kid you guys have like those nylon ones
when your kid do you have one chin yeah
you look like your favorite yeah yeah
John that skateboard I know I'm just
it's a good thing I had to not only wear
a fanny pack rose
afraid to cinch his jeans super tight
Jojo has been known to wear a pair of
[ __ ] Johnny fever like jeans that go
well and in Studios 54 in the 7 mami
Gina latest Tom Segura yeah and he's
being like I can see the crack of his
rump yes got I can see how much change
in his pocket and at the Comedy Store I
can see how he was counting on my shoes
so in rows start laughing so I started
clowning on Rogen's shoes and his laces
were laced so tight I went is there some
Marathon happening tonight I do not know
about I remember I they so Tyga
he was the comfy though I remember so
tight so yeah simply he's also got big
feet he's got big hands big feet and I
happen to know for a fact a real piece
on him yeah yeah yeah I know
I'm very well yeah I'm very aware
there's got a big old heavy piece and I
think big big I've never seen him but I
think he's got big offensive balls just
big bore balls like over anything yeah
he's got big he's got all that
testosterone he just got he's always
been like aggro he's just got those big
heavy well I'll say this you have the
biggest balls I've ever I got some balls
on me you have the biggest grandfather
claim maybe that's why I was so big and
like red and low yeah they're like a
maroon low depends it was you saw it on
a hot day
I've seen those balls more than besides
mine more than anyone's balls oh I hate
Jay sketchy with his dick like is that
cool dick he's got a hell of it I can't
really tell you I know his balls are
decent but not like yours dude
jay is a jay is a sleeper Jay who looks
like a [ __ ] the computer guy he is
and then he takes his shirt off his chin
and he take and if he takes his pants
off he's paying right now he's got a
hell of a body he's strong as balls got
an amazing body though he's like his
aesthetically he's got a very good body
yeah like he looks like he looks like a
a Greek like if you you know there's
Greek armor plates like his body looks
like that and then it like assume then
he's got that crazy dick these are crazy
they said bullet black is it's got it's
very jaws very dark spear it's you know
those lollipops you have as a kid the
rocket ones that were blue why
it's like that but fifty shades of brown
I saw it and it was just and it had a
mind of its own it was kind of it's got
a curve to create a sniff yeah it won't
lick you but a sniff it was licking it
was almost like he was standing there
and I swear to god it was moving it had
an angry head it's more you know I'm
saying married he right I'd I be the
only time I saw him really freaked out
when he was like what the hell is going
on is in college we're playing poker
playing strip poker you know in college
to try and get girls naked guys trying
to get naked have some fun and we're
drinking and J was having a bunch of
drinks and he was like perps trying to
lose cuz he knew he was hiding this a so
I mean ace I mean his fat did yeah yeah
that I kind of knew about and everyone
else had no idea cuz he's the shy kid
from CSU's Brendan's brother yeah so
we're playing he's like Oh Blotz again
socks off
pants I'm like no just one sock it's a
long night taking trip take it easy then
J loss games oh there goes my shirt and
I'll take this off Mike all right man
we'll take it easy cuz shy guys and
nudists and then a boom pants come off
underwear and then all of a sudden no
I'm sorry pants come off
oops that's ours ankles and then goes
oops lost to two two pair loses to three
and then he just pops up this girl's
right there and he goes yeah Jesus
Christ it's just this at me to moment
elephant trunk flapping on a table like
a wild sprinkler did he do the
helicopter while doing a helicopter we
knew you know he was like he was like
that mannequin that you see at the auto
stores that wave in the wind believable
yeah my buddy can't got him drunk to get
it out though my buddy can't used to do
that to kids with weed he had the
biggest or biggest take on the planet
big big stinking for a reason to get it
I used to rest when you'd be doing your
homework he would rest on your shoulder
that's how big it was it would just sit
you just he's one of those like he's
like the the newly yoga teacher yoga
person once you know they're taking yoga
or a vegan well he was also a giant
giant he was a man-child he was like
like LeBron James and and he one time he
I kept [ __ ] with him and he goes if
you keep doing that I'm gonna beat you
with my dick
Wow it's so good see missile club yeah
yeah and I know you're not gonna be
please tell me there would be and he
started to wrestle
Davian remember I was a wrestler and he
wasn't and it didn't much matter because
he was a man-child and he was a it's
crazy athlete doctor basketball 14 he
started clubbing you with his 18 years
old as dick was his dick was a little
bit bigger than the average horses it
looked like Greg Oden hanging from his
leg that is correct that is correct sir
it was a little bigger than me his dick
and he got atop me and I tried to turn
and it is an instinct as a wrestler you
turned to your stomach not when you're
wrestling with got trying to Club you
with this that's right and then I he got
his knees exciting little ones this one
I was 130 pounds this is a 230 pound man
and all muscle again a man tries 18 and
he began to beat hood in your room he
began to nope no no well I don't know
were you going to story but yeah he hit
my friends were giggling and laughing
and and you saw here at Helena you you
could hear this on my back
good god man and then we all had a laugh
and but I got nicely done
I have been beaten by the dick yes I was
under eyes by this man's dick yeah I got
beaten I've shaved me to is right but
yeah I got flogged by my friends
dong do so he just know that they're
minute really can do that dude how about
I went to yoga I'm bound back in the hot
yoga - yoga yesterday for the first time
it's a different it's a different vibe I
went to one off rose to where it's super
Venice on girls soup you ain't lying lot
of super Venice II there even when I'm
in when I'm you mean you mean
so when you say Venice II are you saying
it's a lot of patchouli oil and a lot of
smells in there or is it not a lot of
deodorant a lot of athletic shoes you're
shaving girls are ridiculous the guy's
very granola very you know hi open
redoing right open with gasoline in it
then they're all like this communities
then they've giggle all the time if I'm
in that state of mind I'm there I can be
a yoga man I jump two feet into the pool
one but you are the big giant but also
I've been done in a while so it takes me
a while to you know to get into it I get
there and you're off a little tight no
you're not yo yogi I'm good I'm pretty
good at Yoga
yoga so I was doing it get into it and
then they're like lay on you lay on your
back and I want you just you know and
I'm into it man I mean I'm in the zone
I'm into it's all hot in there and they
go the teacher goes I just want everyone
to lay on their back and say a word that
means something to you maybe it's
gratitude maybe for some of you it's
appreciation but I just want you to say
it out loud so I can hear everyone's
eyes are closed there's nothing to be
embarrassed about and I'm like here we
go and there's so many girls in the room
and I yet it made me laugh because I
swear it if you took apply so I heard
you can hear the guys you know the guys
are like you know appreciation growth
and then you hear the girls all at once
go trust Trust trust haha oh like all of
them god wow you can see like this yeah
that's very interesting that is a
difference because I was it can remind
me had asked what fun how I said Cafe
Gratitude fun trust guys a fun foot
that's great trust Vaughn funds the best
word it's Philly respond or play how
about those two words yeah things are
too serious you're mine bro well it's
too serious than their fun or tour play
you want to sound like a meathead here
trust Trust trust appreciate fun fun is
the best word it was all I was in I was
in Cafe Gratitude which is a vegan place
and with mice yeah and I was like I'm
gonna get some fire on my flower I want
to get him some soup he was hungry and
so as I ordered some lentil soup and
some some Buffalo cauliflower some [ __ ]
and the woman the two gals who were
young and they were very sort of like
what you would do what you would expect
from a vegan restaurant the waiters job
that did the gals at the in the coal get
up the matching white yeah they were
their top take my order yes yeah and
still they had their hair up and they
were very a lot of feminine moon energy
a lot of moon energy you know and and
she said and she's and I guess this is
what they do she goes and and so here's
the question of the day what are you
letting go of today even throw your son
yeah and I said I said I said well I
guess I I said yeah
I said I've kind of figured out in a way
what not to think about and she said but
what are your goals and I said hey I
said I'm making 725 an hour I go I'm
living my goals I'm living my calls
let's not do this just true because I'm
51 and I and I'm that and it's true a
place for it though no and they stopped
everything in there your living your
goals
what's the secret how do you do it and
I'm Eric I looked at I go well I'll tell
you exactly how you come to LA and you
fail for a long time you keep failing
and then you have a couple of successes
but in those success there's a lot of
failures you say how old are you ladies
and they look twenty times what I said
well a fail for another you know thirty
forty years and come talk that's right I
go I'm thirty years older than you by
probably and that's how what do you guys
want to do the aunts probably not
serving this [ __ ] vegan food so go
follow that you're gonna fail many many
times but eventually if you have talent
you might make it yeah and then you can
live your goals yeah but I when I sat
down there they go they're in the get up
they it's like a weird like think of
nurses get up but like a shitty Moton
like Matt gray kind of shitty color yeah
and the stuff it looks like clothes when
you throw up in kindergarten a throw
down on the floor anyways they come by
and they go the word of the day is
fruition fruition like very cool hey all
takes God you know yeah and like what's
that mean for you're like ah not doing
this man not doing this with my waitress
yeah go get my goddamn latte what are we
doing man it's actually a form of
procrastination all that stuff can be
they won't deal with real world yeah all
that stuff in my opinion is a form of
high-tech procrastination so you'll hear
a lot of people say things like this you
know what man I'm just taking some time
for myself and trying to get centered
I'm just trying to focus on me I'm just
focusing on me alright dude listen
here's how you do it things are going
well you that's right so these are going
well what do you want and then go get it
and be working on that all the time I
would see this with acting all the time
do they come this cut this town with
dreams and everything else but what
happens is they're spending all their
time doing anything but acting how many
you in class how many often are you
writing all the time are you always
performing somehow anyway you can are
you
getting better that way are you getting
undeniable so when you walk into the
[ __ ] room
you are undeniable what are you doing
you know you wanted to stand up what do
you say stand up are you writing
everything and performing as much as pot
as much as possible even from the mirror
otherwise everything else is and what
would happen was really interesting they
would create a community around
themselves of people who got into in the
same money talk saying the same lines
yes detoxing riri centering and all the
stuff and they would have essentially
they'd have a slow nervous breakdown for
a long period of time until they would
give up on acting because their big
realization was I'm not here for that
actually I'm here to help people through
their process because they didn't make
it yeah and then you become a healer a
guru yeah yesterday that all does that's
very nice card does that does that bring
you happiness its material oh actually
does yeah is a cars fastest [ __ ] I
worked my ass off for it I will see you
guys never yes will never be punched in
the face lot you got really good it's
something you're getting really good and
another thing it's it's it's it's
focusing on exactly what you're supposed
to do that's fascinating to me because
we all to an extent do it a little bit
is look what do you want what do you
want okay you have to do that all day
just practice that you know then you
have a work father's word other day is
basic [ __ ] yeah yeah do the do the work
do the work
it's like writers how was Brea it was
awesome we almost sold out Sunday I love
bread thank you for coming out they did
they didn't expect you know Sunday's
party salad is gonna be tough almost
salt although it says everyone says
Sunday's are tough boys it all comes I
do don't do Sundays for this reason this
reason they grant I want to be my family
but yeah Sunday's is always being great
to me yeah you've you've been selling
like a [ __ ] and I'm still really
pissed about it but Brea was fun though
right I love birthday was great I got I
got Arizona this Wednesday I'll tansy
and then I got Phoenix live Valentine's
Day where'd it go on there brother
yeah that's if your wife's happy it's a
big comedy day she's in Utah I refuse to
do Valentine's Day when they make a
Hallmark and made-up holiday it makes me
angry but celebrate Halloween Satan's
day I I because I'm a Satanist
I say i'ma say do you take Columbus Day
off
uh I don't you take Martin Luther King
Day Off I am and are you listening to
that I do this is bullsh lino
yeah how do you not take his death yes I
did you celebrate Malcolm next day I
don't I don't know now do you um oh I'm
not going to Vancouver I know just until
you know Vancouver my shows cancelled
does that mean my show's canceled I'm
not sure I think you probably figure
this out I don't think I don't know
really
we're brie booking us to come back yeah
we feel bad about that client now
there's a reason you get sold of kuvera
Vancouver's on my favorite pink uber
don't be mad at me cuz they're
rescheduling for me to afford you have
to shoot you have to shoot you don't
have my control yeah yeah um what can
you do though are you saying you've been
watching the Olympics I've not watched
one I'm just I'm so into it I am too I
love it I need to watch like the ice
skating I I swear to God
I find it riveting and I've always had
have you seen find it in locking then
you're gonna love this you can't make
any mistakes when they throw the person
have you seen the 15 year old who's from
Russia who scores perfect no so all the
Americans go up this Canadian is just
this daya be so goes if at the time went
us number one this girl had a great the
first triple axel ever to be happen in
the Olympics she looks vicious and then
this Russian goes up goes oh you [ __ ]
think you can do this apparently she's
basically like the biggest prodigy of
all time by skating yes she's 15 let me
see she beat her only other competitor
can giving clothes is also on the
Russian team who hasn't lost in
something like seven years and she beat
her at the the Nationals I love this
[ __ ] let me she's ready 15 well a lot of
them are that age you know I mean
they're not those no no she's one of the
youngest ones yeah really fifteen to be
this good is stupid really man and some
people are just you watch it like wow
yeah and then you know for the for the
US there's a brother and sister combo
just weird as last week guys thinking
myself god why having a brother and
sister kind of dominate they come up
together and do it I mean we don't
really know what we're looking at but
it's pretty cool so look the us were in
first place of score 73 like Oh 73 is
good this girl just shits on that
release did she get a perfect score I
think perfect 170 she liked a high 158
or something so and she saves all her
jumps for the second portion and should
do three jumps back-to-back which is
unheard of their same like no one can do
it yes really I don't know why just I
just don't [ __ ] hook onto things I
was like oh now I'm balls deep in the
Olympics and they opened ceremonies for
South Korea did you see a chin no you
should be ashamed I know it's sudden oh
my god it was so corny and the the
[ __ ] special effects are so [ __ ]
it's like they haven't it's like they
just have no clue how the real held the
world's like it's tough oh my god then
they had they had this fake drone scene
or the drones make the signs and then
even even the Olympic rings and even
they go
I've actually shot that but several
months ago but due to the wind but it's
all phony can tell it's all [ __ ]
Photoshop it was so bad it was hard to
watch it was so bad I heard that there
was some sort of weird thing with the
drones malfunctioning because it was a
hack
because fake oh it was a hack they did
it look real and then just then they had
this these dancers and people singing it
was a [ __ ] show they need to update it I
hear how the holy [ __ ] there it's
freezing my buddies to have security
yells are they yes for this Tongans out
there though look look ready no one's in
the stands yeah when they all they
announced their unknowns in the stands
also they had to cancel the Big Ear
competitions the downhill slopes and
moguls because the winds so bad it's so
freezing the wind's bad there's the
worst opening ceremony I've ever seen
damn powerful Shaun White yeah man flag
tomato
oh can we talk about Nathan chin hey if
you're not no first of all hold on
before you play this Nathan chin is like
art he's supposed to win all the Gold's
great he's can still do it
this
that he's doing the today a short
haircut tamil his first time Oh No even
though broadcaster who cell layer
something who this man is but human is
his partner who competed in the Olympics
before her and him are the analyst and
he goes that is the worst I've ever seen
that young man do its first time at the
Olympics and he's supposed to be like
our Michael Phelps and ice skating he's
young as [ __ ] all dude it's the worst
you've ever seen he kept falling ah but
he can still win all the Gold's it's
just it doesn't mean too much like his
warm red horse Shawn white is not in
this Olympics right he is how dare you
yes yes so he supposed to be our big
thing you have all your tea he had all
his teachers Mike good luck Nathan did
you please catch her oh come on - how
about that dude he did it he's like I
guess we'll kiss you do that you do that
all you ain't get no kiss now you do
that over and he in that cold eyes hand
to the are they married yes that's him
that's a bond can you imagine being
around each other that side you better
love that person it's like a working
relationship and yeah we have America a
little bit of rough goat and I kind of
killed it but this the suit how come we
never makes I get her look at her how
can everybody not get on the US team of
doing this it'll never make sense to me
what's it called
curling curly how can you and I not do
this bride how why are you know not only
just a piece to it Gail fat those people
are well y'all out of shape they're it's
not a sport well it's just not it looks
pretty to scale right so you could be
pretty difficult though I guess it would
be but you know that's a bar game like I
know there's technique that plays
shuffleboarding yeah I find her
attractive I don't know who that is but
she's something about her there I said
it out the luge the luge is another
sport they're an athlete you're an
athlete dude yo hard to [ __ ] but look
look all you have to do is just lie down
oh no T that's like watching like going
all you do is throw your left right hand
no come on dude they have to make I
don't know do their reaction skills and
if they crash they're [ __ ] so
it did it's giving me some [ __ ] yeah you
gotta learn the course yeah I don't know
but come on man you just got to make
like a corpse done what about the
bobsled team that's that's again that's
you gotta push it olara techne you're
gonna be very powerful Walker
hey guys like you but very powerful guys
who push a bit and have a lot of I'm too
tall mm-hmm that doesn't okay
very thick very strong huge legs yeah
and they push push and then they get in
and then they go down but you put this
all it's all like its timing yeah it's
speed you know there's always timing and
skill and everything reaction and it's
all obviously I'm [ __ ] around
obviously at that level there's all
these nuances and everything else but
it's the weight they don't update the
Olympics though I agree
like how about the crotch a little bit
not really how about the cross country
skiing and then they shoot things it
takes like several hours oh man it's the
I don't know what the hell they're all
then they got the snowshoes also I I
don't like I don't care yeah and then
that's another sport won't have any
people are competing but uh did you win
a gold in the sport that nobody else
it's like that you win in rope like that
time I met that kid in he goes I'm
Olympian I oh [ __ ] you're Olympian where
he goes I'm in the handball team yeah
damn you like genius I'm actually not
I'm of reserve all right well is there a
kickball team because I'd like to sign
up here they are here here and you got
special I know it's tough but you can't
we update the Olympics yeah you want to
take wrestling out yeah yeah that really
know what think wrestling up but you
leave this [ __ ] makes me super mad I
guess there's two skills you got to do
cross country and kill people but how
weird is it it's very I got watch
someone like a what do we do maybe it's
a military thing that the Norwegian
military like started doing nope
definitely not some was like you know
what what if we just like snow shoot
[ __ ] far as [ __ ] and then shot [ __ ]
on the wing just to mix it up be a
sniper but will also be on it yeah I
could just some of them like whoa what
is going on here biathlon the biathlon
it isn't interesting but very its
Olympics a show old school man but the
old the track and field and a wrestling
I love you I love all the lipids
laughs with just some of its
figure-skating some of it's so old
downhill skiing is badass [ __ ] downhill
ski moguls
Oh oh my god and and even the giant
slalom though those guys go down like
they're hitting 90 miles an hour oh yeah
when I tweet this out maybe saw it made
in so don't cheat if you did tell me you
know we're the most Olympic athletes in
the Winter Olympics come from from
America where the most come from yeah
hold on
Wood State hold on where the most
athletes come from in the Olympics I'm
gonna say I'm gonna say this I'm gonna
tell you why I'm gonna say Colorado
because in the altitude and also from
there well we know the out student also
the training center but you want to
train there also I think feel like with
the snow in the mountains there are more
Olympic winter sports it's easier to
kind of train up there I don't know
come on tonight it's like in their blood
you know I'm saying like skiing Colorado
but you think like there's snow in
Wyoming Utah this snow on the East Coast
structure in Colorado but in colorado
like like we grew up like it's like it's
like being raised in California or
Hawaii like where's the most best
surface in the world oh I say there's
more time outside yeah but so it's like
in Colorado like it was even like oh you
don't ski like all of us would ski or
snowboard it's literally it's like
playing you know surfing here but you
brought her here where the [ __ ] you just
grew up doing it right so there you
should be ignore accustomed to it and
just some people just take it to the
next level it did lazybone she's not she
hasn't when it's the downhill skiing
soon it might be tonight god I gotta
watch this stuff yeah gotta watch this
this is Lana she's she's she's killing
she's not small by the way Lindzi well
I've met her yeah me too she's a
powerful woman
I'm sundae she's imagine someone like
Lindsay Vonn would give you the hungry
eyes you're kind of her type I never
know why are you smiling
well I'm not smiling I'm just saying you
might be right let's go back to the wind
interesting yeah it is interesting
she's yeah she's a beast never know
she's a sexy woman man you're too light
you're a Cu I'm too light in the ass you
can't step to that unless you're ready
you got to be you got to be Brendan
Schaub strong oh yeah I don't know if
I'm ready for that but um he'll be you
bet
get ready training kids best get ready
but there's there's a snowboarder or no
I'm sorry skier on the mobiles she was
young - I think she was 16 she this one
super beasty girl really super beasty
and then you find out her dad was a
world champion her mom was like a rock
so she
so you see her go ask tutelage and it's
funny cuz I say the same thing - like
Joe's like how do you think you do down
have you tried the Mobile's I tried when
I was a kid and I was like dad my knees
would literally blow out my [ __ ] if I
tried moguls and they show the girl
going and you're like oh my god cuz her
knees are going crazy
and the guy goes - misconception where
people think their people's knees are in
trouble it's harder than your knees it's
actually not
he was cuz the way they got the skates
actually no pressure on the knee alright
there's not a lot of knee problems you
saying now that's coming from the expert
who's saying I I assume there's knee
problems just from the sheer force of it
but you saying it's a misconception
because people go oh my god their knees
he goes the technique is so good in the
skis these watching those guys come down
I've seen some of the Olympic guys I in
person
that's not training and it's [ __ ]
nuts though she's the power skaters the
speed skaters with her legs giant legs
huge she can take she gon take a she got
a legs I'm a fan of limp expand I love
it - I love him I prefer the I prefer
the Summer Olympics aren't they worth
the night they're coming to LA right I
have no idea look bring it up chin
Summer Olympics yeah next summer
olympics i think it's i think we get in
2024 is it 2024 2020 2020 Tokyo 2018
yeah Davis Tokyo yeah 2020 I gotta get
ready dude I got to start shooting dude
my wrestling is just not ready it's hot
it's just hot I'm not kidding I got to
start [ __ ] wrestling and I don't know
if I'm gonna get into boxing or I'm
gonna do wrestling or both
you know maybe tennis well tennis is a
given because okay tennis was a strong
but my job is so stup you know what
frustrates me and listen I should be
known to talk about this I've had times
in the in the Octagon in the UFC where I
had you know training camp and I've been
getting ready for my whole life then you
show up and just drop an egg it's just
not your night but
nothing frustrates me more like when
they showed that kid who I know he's
young but it's their moment and they've
they've been training all their lives
and they put four years they knew this
exact date and they go out there just
laying at it egg it frustrates me so bad
I'm like god damn it you had one job man
you got one job but I actually think it
was under pressure yeah I know exactly
what they go through it's just like [ __ ]
yeah yeah you get in your own head you
did don't just don't [ __ ] this up don't
[ __ ] this putt up you know but to get to
this point they went through Nationals
they did the world competition they won
their they won their and the girl who's
commentate or talked about it when he
was like and when it came down to the
big thing in the Olympics do that for
the did to make the team I just [ __ ]
the commentator for Olympics goes you
can win the world you can win all these
accolades but there she is Tara Lipinski
and I forget her on the plane Penske we
had a talk no no it's not Bob Costas
it's it's Laurie this guy no yes he's
really good John we're Johnny we're he's
really good that's not matters coat
Count Dracula he's actually great yeah
he's amazing commentator but both of
them are really good but he was she was
she's him look at his hair yeah yeah his
hair is crazy Wow he's he is very very
buoyant flamboyant yeah but he knows his
[ __ ] I know but that's amazing mm-hmm
look at his hair but I'm ghetto I'm
talking that you know I listen to a lot
of analyst and stuff like that though
these are some of the best I've ever
heard I'm sure so clear and you have to
look at when they're doing the figure
saying they have to notice every little
mishap and cue I think I'm just like
damn and the way they explained it so
good but she would tara lipinski was
saying that you know she won worlds she
went national she won all these
accolades and then we get to limit use
there's just no pressure like it I can't
duplicate it yet yeah I get that I get
that but yeah Russian wet yeah huge well
they del tell you she's 15 what were you
doing at 15 I was balls deep and
probably NBA 2k Brighton candy up the
ass playing football
my parents yeah well I've definitely
wasn't representing Russia you're
limping
six hours a day or whatever it is you
know Tony Jefferies good buddy my my
boxing coach he's been on the show
before he was in Olympic so they find
these kids young so Tony got put in the
Olympic program yeah but be put in
programs when he was 7 for the box
approach so they they groomed him since
he was 7
he's gonna have to go through all these
steps they're now the out of the look
whatever the class of 40 that they
groomed from 7-10 of those kids make it
they like it so it's all these I got
he's such a badass
he's a handsome kid I want to call Tony
handsome I would you talk about that
potato nose yeah no smiling teared he's
a handsome guy lucky that was my very
first day there really that's my first
day meeting Tony
no [ __ ] yep look how young he looks look
at bring up Tony now he has three kids I
met for coffee later he goes mate it's
horrible because he has two young ladies
three young ones he's just he's like it
took us 12 minutes to get in the car
today yeah yeah I'm like yet three
brother yeah I want three so bad but uh
yeah Tony's been punched in the face
many many times yes he has but he's
still he's still got a manly look to
call and I know I'm just messed around
he just have a potato nose though like
he's aged of 10 look at him look ever
here's this picture up at Nike town
that's awesome does he knows he has his
picture up in Nike town yeah Santa
Monica when they're doing some collab
with yeah [ __ ] model in the Nike
store Nagar he's a good-looking dude
with switch where he dresses up I will
never forget I've told her I'm here a
long time where I will never forget when
me and Tony were hanging out and you
know he's from England he really know
how it works over here and I ordered a
new bird he didn't understand how tuber
works
I told you story I told this book Jin
has a head so you don't notice down over
works so you guys they just pick you up
I go how do you explain ty oh yeah they
just picking it [ __ ] yeah it's uber man
what do you think easy
oh cool where we gone I was taking the
dinner so because we want to fight so I
go to a fight him and his mates like to
drink you know I don't so I take him
dinner
him and his but him and his buddies
decide to go out to a bar I go
home again this uber picks me up and
he's like this only in America they just
pick you up they speak up and every time
the uber comes by you know you want to
see so I go like this
well Tony goes out and drinks gets like
pretty drunk and he walks outside and he
thought I was just flagging random cars
down he understand I was ordered to BRR
so he's off Main Street in Venice he
sees a pretty singles flag just car down
this guy picks him up and be like where
he going Tony tells him he's like I'll
give you a ride 20 says he's driving
he's I guess is great man this is so
easy and the guys like yeah yeah yeah
and then he it was an Asian guy so don't
get mad chin and Tony say he's sitting
there and he's going down the road down
Pacific and the guy goes he reaches in
now Tony's Olympic boxer undefeated
professional boxer like a man's man does
not joke around being gay he's like do
like he doesn't play like that yeah I
can't grab his ass or flick his dick or
he does not play like he's like Jay does
not play like that
and the guy goes to reach for his dick
Antonio's what da [ __ ] me and the guy
goes bro you flagged me down he goes
what and the guy goes you suck dick you
suck dick you suck my dick and so he's
like absolutely not and Tony says he's
like Tony said he's pinned against the
wall like though this fist up like this
just don't [ __ ] touch me and the guys
like I'm not an uber man I'm just trying
to [ __ ] your psyche dick he's like
happen he goes well get out us no you
give me a ride home [ __ ] the hell so he
makes him give a ride home he makes this
poor guy who a ride home
the guy gets this point and right yet
he's holding his fists like this goes if
you try anything else and then right for
a Chinese guy goes come on you suck my
dick
this thing went so he's like no god damn
it and then Tony like state goes bro
I don't know what the [ __ ] happened but
my uber was not like yours I have to
explain to them it's an oh that's so far
but is that oh my just wave downgrade to
Prius and the guys like yeah I'll do it
such a great stories great yeah I was
laughing so hard because if you know
Tony but poor guy was like Jesus man
yeah yeah his potato nose though god I'm
gonna start doing um you watch fights as
we get it watch the fights Julie the
stream woman you're uh no I breathe
water mine
would piss me I'm a bottom on
pay-per-view but I didn't record uh and
I went back to watch it
add hold on I hope it was gon fight
again not I [ __ ] up yeah
twenty 120 I spent a hundred and twenty
eight dollars you noticed they increased
babies by $4.99 oh you would notice that
because he used to be 59 that by the way
um so I thought Luke fought they looked
sensational broke you all romero's I
want to get your take on this but here's
my take I thought Luke looked really a
break you'll ruin he didn't break
swelling okay it wasn't Brooke really
good kicks low kicks and stuff like that
I got to tell you what I was really
impressed was it was Yoel Romero 's
defense his ability to not get hit but
stand it seemed like he was standing in
the pocket no he got kicked and then his
explosion and his insane just those
looping shots and and then then two I
think was a right a really straight
right it was well after the left I can't
loop behind the ear yeah me and rubber
Tex and I went the only can't bother him
about this fight and I actually picked
Luke to win especially we came with his
mind right the only thing I bothered me
was Luke has this weird block with left
hand like the you know bisman Conibear
off the bell for did with his cake like
there's there's certain things we have
this block were susceptible to the left
hand huh now I don't know if this is a
case of him not working on it or
whatever because it hit him behind the
head and that's what rocked him I was
more I was more upset marcado didn't get
there in time to stop him from eating
just literally literally literally just
a flush uppercut yeah like you just
pinned against one you just you have yo
Romero who's a Ford he came in so fast
42 years old Knight my name is 40 it's
42 look it up
who's 42 and just literally a pass if
someone said hey bruh and punch his
candles hard you can in the face but
that's what he did in Luke Rockhold
space it happened so fast he jumped on
him and there's no candy so far away you
can't be so that right okay so far away
yeah dude
ah he's 40 40 yeah but he's he's he's
such a freak
and we've been talking about him from
day one you know I feel that greater I
felt bad for Luke man
I did too I felt I felt really really
bad reach out to fuse coaches and just
like God
it's just such a bummer that because he
came in ready he worked really hard on
this in his camp from what I hear it
bothers me he's not 8k anymore I know
you had to get up so Julie looks really
good or do you not like don't you think
he's striking and everything looked
really good like it's glow I've never
seen a throw low kicks like that I
thought his low kicks were good and they
were doing damage and yeah you know he's
assi it's the it's the smart one that
wins a race of you know like this and
five rounds and he was you know he was
being calculated and controlled to me
Luke's lost his swagger really yeah he
lost it when I think he lost it
that night he got knocked out by Bisbing
and then wife's when he fought branch I
didn't think he looked the same yeah he
had he had a little bit of ring rusty
ate some punches from Branson that's not
the Luke you know he tried to warm out
and broke branch was which isn't an easy
task and we fight you all I just didn't
I don't know something all the skills
there things that he just looks like
he's lost a little bit of swagger see I
thought he looked crisp as hell to me
like him I did it name what sniffing a
shot to the land well that's a thing so
letting leg kicks that's yeah but I
thought it's punching everything he was
in and out moving he didn't touch well
we didn't really touch that jab start
laying a little bit but when you're the
longer guy that's that's gonna happen
and so that's my so that's that's what
I'm saying is that I looked to me looked
so on point and then I just was watching
you well like do that cross guard his
defense was phenomenal he sat on that
Wells defense or was either his
combination of both I thought Luke
really didn't pull the trigger but again
I'm if I'm Luke can you hurt his corner
say that crazy Bob cook tell him hey we
got a lot of time left you know take it
easy
that's what you want doing a five-round
fight especially against Scotty like uol
yeah he just never it was just and maybe
he's waiting for but there are times
when y'all would explode what y'all does
your goes it's like a video game if it's
a stamina thing it goes boom and then
halves it then that's it and it doesn't
reset that fast we goes poem yeah boom
yeah and then so he would explode in
that first round early thus a crown and
then he would you know Luke with loose
limb sit there and recover
Tibbie you got a you want to wear it out
you make him don't let him just sit on
just sit in front make up dar make them
know how to recent let that right
tell them keep resting okay resting I
just I just that killer instinct just
wasn't there for me for Luke this fight
what that's interesting yeah so so I
just I still think technically an
athlete and athletically and overall
package Luke is still the best middle
way in the world that being said I think
you're Romero was the easier matchup for
him than Robert Whittaker I thought
Robert Robert Whittaker verse Luke
scares me for Luke why because first of
all well and beat him yes and as well
but is it yo else learning curve and
he's such an athlete I feel like
learning curve he's 40 yeah but your
reveals the same every time we've seen
him is it the same every time there's
nothing odd right King seems like it's
cotton yeah although it's same every
time yeah the striking is not technical
no it's no who's just assuming and it
knows just as explosive and more
technical Whitaker Robert Whittaker yeah
he's fast
oh he's also very tough to take down he
has now I would assume Luke's game plan
with him would be destroyed him down to
the ground but I don't know if we see
Whitaker Luke well Whittaker Whittaker
is a nightmare for those guys he's the
perfect you know he's the he's the right
size his dama hits like a Mack truck
yeah hard to take down here's all this
confidence now mm-hmm
I don't know I just I felt so bad for
Luke I did too
I did too this is kind of the time
though when you decide like when when
you know you're up against it and and
you confer Luke remember yeah he lost a
Bisbing he was out for how long over a
year he did the modeling contract he did
all that stuff
he was beef with the UFC and then he
comes back to fight state we branched a
little bit of ring Ross he looked okay
in that fight I thought there was a lot
of holes in his game there training at
the Nou Camp but he still got it done
and then with your Romero it's like and
then you lose this one it's just like
well the game such a [ __ ] it's such a
and there's so many more well such a
monster so for me like when you lose to
you al Romero
there's no it's he's the best in the
world he I was the lighting you out
comes back well Robert I beat him
I know but Robert the the guy who some
would say be yo L in the jaw Craig I am
Robert Whittaker ready murked walked
literally walked through him
I was like what right now fine take me
down took me down got up boom yeah crazy
when it was a nightmare nightmare do you
think what about woody well again yes in
same game same fashion tell me what that
Dana Ray said that's the fight he's
gonna make cuz you know you'll miss him
wait I agree with them it's not that big
of a thing it shows you what they think
of in turn bells right when your wins he
doesn't get in turn me out can you miss
wait but short notice yours a bigger
dude as far as muscle wise so the weight
cuts a little harder on them so he
missed it by three pans I wouldn't knock
them for it now you all Whittaker to die
that doesn't do much for me I don't know
so town I don't like seeing those unless
it's really close like a like Jones
Gustin or DC Gustin I don't really like
to see rematches because you think
you're I think Whitaker has you all his
number in that he stays he stands on the
outside of the pocket just keeps closing
nightmares just a nightmare that a
striker bet he's just as explosive he's
a better counter puncher top CEOs a
better wrestler Whitaker's better
stamina it's just the younger quicker
faster and more technical I mean don't
get me wrong you're all so goddamn
explosive and talented he can catch on
for sure but I fight ten times I would
bet Robert Robert Whittaker wins at
least seven out of it who does who does
who does
Luc fight next
dude is it Wow would that work I bet
they maybe they give them like a Kelvin
Gastelum or a not what not why I mean
cuz come off win Jack I rang blows all
right look having fought since
Strikeforce be a bad Jacare
[Music]
so Luca probably get bumped down to
probably for now because he realized
what a [ __ ] this this business is what
a [ __ ]
all right it breaks my heart man yeah so
I don't know it's tough to see man you
know there's not a lot of young dudes
but I'll tell you what though and I
tweet this out I was wrong you know I
was talking [ __ ] about you know
blockbuster cards and papers and stuff
like that still you knew Tara on the
pay-per-views but great card man great
card yeah from from the from the first
time the main card with Tyson page or
who I'm a huge fan of people
such fan once you break him down the big
brown breakdown a lot of times on those
breakdowns when I talked about guys I've
been a fan of Pedro for a long time but
a lot of times time constraint I like
him I didn't know a whole lot about the
guy who was fighting he was a you know
great submission I think a rogue in a
shadow he's like all I want to do is go
home whatever make it load my girl drink
beer and get on the Joe Rogan podcast
that's kind love that and then Jake do
you see the Jake Matthews I didn't see
that fire did you see that evil Chinese
man Ling jangling I poked right I
grabbed so oh dude so he's getting
literally so Jake Matthews is a black
belt I'll breathe amazing black belt and
he's doing work and he's wearing the
whole fight but he hasn't been a
guillotine and it's over it's over and
jingling puts his what is it Jin Ling
Zhi Ling Jiang puts his she going Jin
Ling oh my bad I'll get [ __ ] close oh
that's terrible
yeah oh my god now I will say this and
this is kind of known around you know
it's like baseball you know the don't
really talked about the rules but
there's times when you're in those
situations where if he doesn't do that
he loses the fight so worst case in
there I don't believe in I gouge and we
can grab some balls or do whatever you
want to do because if it's it you're
it's you're throwing a Hail Mary there
you really get tap out you get choked on
conscious or they take a point for me
but you live to fight another round
so as dirty as it is and do you see what
Jake did I have not ever zero to see
what Jake did didn't give a [ __ ] because
I get it man cuz most fighters
understanding is I get it man he was
gonna go out if he didn't do that it's
the last harad it's all good things
happen I moved on and he because it was
a great fight
that was my fight I have no tolerance
for that you can blind somebody that way
though oh yeah but yeah I mean your
choke got asleep in your life and
prayers on the line yeah and both these
German have been tough before hi guys
yeah that's [ __ ] up I get it but you
know I'm saying like you're like oh [ __ ]
i'ma lose I'm gonna lose this fight if I
don't do something and cheat it is a
it's cheating for cheating but it can
also end somebody's career it's fighting
though you know people forget this is
the fight it's fighting but under under
specific rules and especially there's no
eye-gouging biting never forget though
what it is that when you pull away all
the fancy lights and the convention
yeah and the sponsors sure you fight
another man yeah yeah but there's no
excuse for I gotcha yeah it's no time
tell them to it's [ __ ] up my make
excuse from but if your life will your
livelihood and your career is on the
line
you're not really like God is poor eyes
it's literally like that's actually
exactly when you have to be that way
that's what that's the mark of character
so the mark of character and the mark of
who you really are is how you behave
under extreme pressure right
so if under pressure you're an eye gouge
oh then you're kind of a piece of [ __ ]
and that's my problem with that's my
problem that kind of behavior so no I
don't condone it be you never I don't in
there so what I'm telling you though
we're like when you're in there if
there's the guys and you see all-time
some of the some of your favorite
fighters when there's a serious problem
they will grab a finger try to break it
it's a you're not allowed to do that
yeah so do you have a problem with that
because that's cheating - you have a
problem that but not nearly as much as I
have a problem with gouging somebody's
eye because you can blind somebody tells
you he's okay it was your line there's
got to be a zero Pathan that's that's
crazy
they've done so plate they didn't take a
point I would I didn't take a point from
crazy how crazy is that
I'd be like hey how about they didn't
really give them a Warren I give you
this watch it how about what the [ __ ]
man but I sold Jake's reaction like I'll
give you this I go like this you know
I'm a very forgiving guy about the human
condition in extreme so I go alright
you panicked you stuck your finger in
his ID but you gotta get out of here
you're disqualified you lose that's what
I would do well there'd been a bigger
problem if jingling would've won but
this Matthews beat the kind of what does
that yeah it was a good fighters back
and forth when they're striking but you
got to be a Jake Matthews fan after this
it's literally it's literally like life
or death therefore jingling it's like
it's been couples for also did he know
was his eyes sure he did I think Jake
said that it's just the heat of the
moment he understands he he was just
like panicking most fighters will tell
you that like we all understand what
most vibes will tell you it's some shady
[ __ ] though but you you actually get it
you got [ __ ] like my wrestling coach
leaders like dude you in trouble like
that you take your thumb and you put it
right in their [ __ ] and rip it
all right I was lucky whether we get
conscious I'm dragging their [ __ ] yet
some dirty [ __ ] yeah let me see the red
skirt chin that's a joke though
oh yeah black belt got your neck Curtis
blades I thought like smart was fought a
very smart fight I thought he looked
really good but that bet Mark Hunt when
he threw that jab and he and Mark Hunt
dipped and threw that perfect right that
overhand right and Curtis place was like
I don't want any more of that thank you
so much I thought he was darkness blades
out a great quote too he goes listen man
I don't like fighting I don't like
getting punched in the face it [ __ ]
hurts on me I'm only doing this for
money so however I can win I don't care
if you guys don't like it I'm gonna take
everyone down I can that's what I'm not
here to get punched in the fan that's
not that great he goes I'm not one of
those guys that go oh I do this for free
in the backyard he goes That's not me
which I love when guys speak the truth
he got their kids here right yeah yeah
because when because when you have these
you know these gangsters the street
cakes oh I'll find em any time anywhere
and we haven't seen him in how many
years now that they're making money like
you want to talk to stalk I'll fight
anytime anywhere I'll fight in the
backyard for free tonight you won't you
full of [ __ ] it's all marketing you're
the same as everyone else your service
man and toxic waste was a thinking
fighter yeah I like not early ami was it
I was like too disappointed I takes Cody
like dude yeah I know you say strikings
getting there and you know no one can
touch him in the training room I thought
it'd look good a strike oh my gosh
attrocious you gotta study so amateur oh
no I'm really worried about him in the
top unless he get specific matchups he's
in a lot of trouble looks right at me
why why do you say like what do you say
I mean it's jab jab double jab you know
so slow is so you so you so Illustrated
like you could tell it was coming from
it's just right ham so that's why he's
getting countered that's why he's just
like [ __ ] this cuz for a guy at Marc
Marc Marc I literally I can't just move
his head he just goes like this I was
back none the most mark Conte can't do
with a guy like JDS or the other guy
like Steve pate there's no just going
like this because Curtis blades is so
slow and it was so predictable I was
like dude quit throwing that one to quit
thrown the doubled in there's no
variation there's no kicks
there's no uppercuts there's no hooks
it's one to one
- he did throw one on - he threw it and
he came back with her but he missed it
it was so amateur
I told Cody dude so what was striking
Sam so Mark Hunt is picking up on your
rhythm and he's gone are you throwing a
left one - so what he does is he goes
here comes that jab again each other and
it can literally anyone that in that
anyone who's a striking that divisions
can give some issues but he's wrestling
so good he's a monster
was he a wrestler was he that was that -
first champ yeah okay and that yeah
his takedown sport you just don't do
that - [ __ ] mark up yeah that's
really good I was like Jesus national
judo champion but for Curtis blades yeah
I don't you know he's a monster but he
hasn't been striking that long right man
and if I was his coach I would tell him
do team everything you don't even want
to I don't want to see you throw that
right hand I just want you to double jab
to get a hold of those legs I don't want
you exchanging with him there's none of
that you know look what happened yeah he
almost lost the fight yeah yeah I'll
tell you what right right now Chris
blades and he lost to Francis and that
fight got you stopped by the refs
because I just won't shut but he fights
Francis in Ghana right now he destroys
him because he'll just take him down he
goes oh my god he has that little
wrestling I'm just gonna destroy the US
he's never gonna do that they're gonna
protect Francis I bet free fights like
JDS next I'm like that but for Curtis
you know you he's such a beast of a
wrestling it's good cardio he's gonna go
for a lot of guys problems however you
know I don't know if the UFC is gonna
build him up like like they should yeah
cuz you look you look at the top guys
you know I'd like to see him again big
good fight for him Derrick Lewis would
be a good fight for them you're meaning
they're fun fights you it's harder to
take the winner there and they're gonna
give him some trouble Kane's gonna be an
issue for him King can wrestle and box
for bricio you don't want to take down
so that's a nightmare of a matchup for
him and then you got you know Overeem
and steep bay
so then you got France step one which
would be a great fight from there's no
way they feed him Francis he would eat
Francis [ __ ] alive
it's just top it but this is the thing
about the UFC it's tough to get there
and then work on striking
it's tough to work get there and work on
yeah and try and get better at like oh I
really need to get better at striking
and you're in the top flight
now in the world and your five seas not
like old lets you wants to give you a
little break
well you were gonna strike camp you got
a strike camp it doesn't yeah well
you're off to the races
yeah John I was a victim of that to you
like you're in this video game and
eventually get to a level where you
don't have all the equipment together
level yeah for Curtis yet it doesn't
really I mean he's wrestling so good he
might be fine I'm just saying is he
fights guy can defend his takedowns you
be in a world of trouble
yeah a guy with world-class strikers
like Mark Hunt is just old-school yeah
he's also older I felt well I felt bad
for Mark man I know I feel bad for the
you guys felt bad for Mark 17 years yeah
you gotta be able to do it all now yeah
great night of fights though man amazing
night of fights when are we gonna see
Cain Velasquez fight again do we know
this year really yeah not steeper at
first but this year yeah interesting
[ __ ] maybe we give him curved blades
mm-hmm do some clear events let's do
some current events sure
all right so someone sent me this and
said it would be Brennan's worst
nightmare mall Santa turns out to be a
serial killer [ __ ] called it man -
what'd I tell you
never trust those mall Santa watch think
of a man who goes you know what I'm just
gonna dress up as Santa while these
little kids sit on my lap said no one
ever Hussein in the head and that's
their nice older gentleman and scaper an
annual mall Santa Bruce MacArthur on
toes 66 uh-huh they found at least six
different body parts from different
different people inside pottery in his
backyard and they think there's gonna be
more to dismembered remains he was like
a gay Santa too so a gay guy and that
was meeting other gay guys and I guess
having sex and then chaos week just
killing him afterwards oh this is a
great movie script but anyways there's
some of his victims victims god damn it
Dean he liked men who looked like me he
liked older men and not Dean's young I
do not recognize these teens 47 Wow do
you like about you and he's a drunk
yeah I was gonna say so those are the
five that we know of that he killed holy
[ __ ]
body parts covered in planters at job
sites suspect worked as the landscaper
and he just put the body parts in there
is there a picture of this guy yeah
dude do you have pictured him as Santa
no I could type that in for me look at
him
you Tyburn I've been what ever is any
man killer no you do though we should
lock up all these Santa's it's [ __ ]
crazy man think thinking of a buddy like
aah is it December I got [ __ ] to do man
where are you going I'm headed to the
Beverly Center cuz I'm saying I'd go
whoa yeah what the hell yeah look at him
of course no deals in each people's they
think they might be him no that's him
look at those eyes and he's hiding
behind a mask look at him sitting there
like he's hiding behind that's a mask
dude look at his eyes now look at how
he's sitting like a like a throne yes I
kill people come to me children it's a
scary movie bro [ __ ] yes dude how about
how about when I what took my son to the
to the grower to gonna meet Santa we my
girls scheduled it like months out which
is weird to me let's just show the [ __ ]
up we get there and I go hey before we
go in the Santa dude do we know any of
his background do we know any was back
out and the elves the hot girls the
elves go that no you know what let me
ask you if you just asked I would love
it if you just give me some sort of
background does anyone know what this
guy does look at him there and they came
back there went he's actually a retired
man in the service and he has a ton of
grandchildren he just likes to do this
in his off-time way that's fair still a
little skeptical but I'd need some proof
but whatever
yeah look at that freaking guy yeah he's
yeah I called it I hate that I'm right
he's hiding me I called this I get
called the curved blades fight but of
course Curtis is gonna take him down at
round after round but of course the mall
Santa murders people you'll be a real
psychopath yeah do you have nothing
better to do that crazy huh guess what I
want my son sir on your lap either now
I'm ass on the other lap why hold my son
we're [ __ ] on you [ __ ]
there are there's a there's a condition
where people get excited about killing
you they it's called a sociopath you but
but it's one thing to kill people right
so they when they look at crime scenes
they can always tell so a lot of times
men who feel like they've been slighted
right like if they they want to look
like a gangster come in kill you like a
great white shark come in hit you in the
head shoot you in the head you know why
I'm done
they get the job done but it's the
people that get off on the act of
killing the sadists
that's what serial killers this guy is
what nightmares are made of
look at him you don't see me on FX
series or some [ __ ] now they have
everything set up - they drugged you and
they do all [ __ ] man mm-hmm like that
[ __ ] guy with the submarine you know
what else I called it he did Logan Paul
go way to go detective he got back onto
YouTube
so within a week of going back on Oh
Mike he does a video where he's tasering
dead mice does he not have advisors so
should you to pull that that small-time
Miller YouTube pulled the video ad spend
the ads right yeah and now YouTube has a
new deal where hates if you put stuff on
that's questionable or that hurts
people's feelings or that's bullying
they take that so you make zero dollars
off they pull the ads now which i think
is the correct thing to do um what's he
where is he doing this what was he doing
it was just him dead mice tasering like
you know when you have a mousetrap in
your backyard to kill the mosque that's
that's going in your house he took those
out that died and then he just tased
like with the actual taser gun the mice
but why would you do that you know I
mean obviously you want to get hits but
this is right after the dead body
thing yeah like that is strange no he
just he's lying by the way the mouse is
dead all right
also and it's just weird though like
just wish for your first video but then
this is what bums me out so he goes even
though I [ __ ] up like I'm an idiot
doesn't feel good to have millions of
people tell you to go die then he
continues say that getting yoked at the
gym and the engagement of the scam
photos up again I'm probably like the
most sound biteable [ __ ] on plan
earth I'm a walking soundbite each yeah
and then he says I'm not this I'm not a
disgrace what other youtuber you know it
can take a three week break and still
get million subscribers man you just
going down the wrong Paul kicked off
this week with now deleted joke about
swung Tide Pods on Twitter man he's just
he needs some sort of you need so to
help him man this come from me yeah
maybe he's just not that he's tone deaf
right he's tone deficit yeah it's well
you know I know you know he likes to be
a shock factor guy and there's so long
one type odd per degree tweet yikes yeah
I know he's gone for shock factor and
stuff like that but you just off man
they can say well I'm about millions
more followers a new Brendan that's fine
but let's see how in the long run how
this works out yeah I don't know it's
it's sloppy it's not straight is that's
no it's not creative right what else you
got to you know about this right Charlie
Sheen and Lenny Dykstra if you have not
seen this I'm not gonna go throw up but
go to The Hollywood Reporter they have
it's called Hollywood's most toxic
bromance the implosion of Charlie Sheen
Lenny Dykstra have you heard this crazy
[ __ ] a little bit it's a little shady
because Lenny Dykstra is you know he he
was in prison he's kind of bankrupt now
you know he's at the time after retired
this is like 2003 is worth 58 million
dollars what from carwashes investments
58 million dollars damn but what
happened to start gambling gambling or
drugs and tax fraud you know the
government thirty million dollars so but
then he was he got really close to a
Charlie Sheen he's trying to be his
adviser and stuff like this now he's
trying to do like a mini doc or
documentary about Charlie Sheen and
himself so you know but there there are
some points he makes that are validated
by other sources yeah other people like
you know Charlie Sheen's drug problem
then you saying how Charlie Sheen knew
he had HIV and gave to these other women
oh he's saying how he saw I think he saw
Charlie getting [ __ ] by a dude yeah
that's what he says side transsexual
yeah yep and you saying that Charlie you
know it was embarrassing that that's why
I kicked him out of his tribe he was he
was just see and then he goes on to say
which this one's a little weird again
he's trying make a documentary but some
people validate that no one can validate
this one that he had this like assistant
or liaison who knew all this stuff about
Charlie and knew about Charlie's you
know escapades with transsexual stuff
like that and he's gonna write it do a
tell-all book about it and Charlie found
out and then this guy like months later
ends up like dad they said he owed heed
on this the oxycontin or something like
that so then lenny dykstra was like he
didn't see Charlie for a while they
seemed does what happened to Larry
that's not his name but what happened to
Larry I can't believe he died and he
goes yeah you want to talk all that [ __ ]
gave him a bad batch and winked out Oh
could have been just him talking but
sure I'm sure but then they talk to one
of Charlie's close friends he goes let's
say Charlie did it Charlie sure as [ __ ]
wouldn't tell when he died true yeah
which is a legit point yeah and then
also one of the reasons Charlie's pissed
off at him is because Lenny was doing
this deal and Charlie go well what's in
it for you and goes well figured out
late and he found out he's getting 5%
off the back end so the last text
Charlie sent him was something like dude
I kept asking you and the truth is
you're trying to not only clean my house
would clean my [ __ ] clock he's like
[ __ ] you have there have there been any
women that hey that that came out as
being infected by truck yes
his ex-wife who's suing him what yes she
was a former porn star his ex-wife does
is hiv-positive look I don't know if
she's excited hiv-positive but she's
actually in the store you can see her Oh
yep has known Denise Richard no no no
got her used to be with Denise Richards
truncheon I think your name's Brooke
Mueller still married during HIV
diagnosis no that's not her so Lenny
died she was trying to tell him and so
was his family his you know his father
Martin Sheen's is huge yeah Hollywood
lad RIA Margie was telework with
yeah Martin was trying to tell him hey
come out with let people know you have
HIV before it gets broke the way you
don't want to happen so was Lenny
Dykstra and then I think the Esquire or
sorry not Esquire one of those [ __ ]
tabloids released it before he could he
went down the rabbit thing you know what
he came out and Lenny Dykstra was the
one who said you know I to the media
mind actually is not a good guy you know
he went down that rabbit hole of
pleasure right he just went all the way
I just know people who know him have
spent time with him and the stories are
from pretty reliable sources the stories
are he was always considered a really
nice guy people who worked with him and
just yes he's a loving generous is [ __ ]
I know guys I know
waiters he used to work wait on him and
I know them well and they they got such
huge tips from Charlie I know a lot of
people who really like these guys such a
nice guy like he was always really nice
and I think he just the drugs and
following that sort of like that
the great god of sensation you know just
always wanting to get off in one way or
another and it gets worse and worse you
get more results by living with three
porn stars yeah got these people that
come along and with that when they see
blood in the water to die summer
obviously a sick of Fanta guy doing
whatever he can get his take advantage
of yeah is the actual California law be
if you have HIV and you don't tell
someone I'd I know I know it's I don't
know but I know it's definitely you can
get sued if you have actually think it's
required by a law if you have into
involves that you have HIV positive it
is a felony felony hate everybody which
is shabaan attacks of course you should
be without informing their parent of
course I totally think so
before we move on I piss hard all this
drug let's go - let's go guys do it
together
what else you got gin let's start with
this NBC had to apologize and then fire
guy a commentator for saying something
about during the opening ceremonies
about Korea and Japan the gun agent
descent nope I don't know what he is
joshua cooper was Asian
Rob What did he say though okay even you
know about this Brian so it has to do
with the you know Japan
occupying Korea from 1910 to 1945 there
it is and they're very yeah okay so the
country which occupied Korea and added
but every Korean will tell you that
Japan is a cultural technology and
economic example has been so important
to their own transfer move Todd I was
like the worst is you don't say that
yeah it's just yeah it'd be like each
other right Oh
given the Otzi's credit these the [ __ ]
is out there Japanese yeah the Japanese
the basic lanes were going the Japanese
came in and the Japanese came in and and
took that country over didn't allow the
Korean see even speak their own language
in some cases by the way it's very
important also remember that the
Japanese forced forced Korean young
Korean girls by the thousands into
prostitution and they were forced to
accompany the troops as comfort women
yet they were also put in brothels and
they were forced to have sex with you
know a fifty you know ten men 15 minutes
a day girls as young as 13 years old is
he just a figment yeah sounds like very
ignorant statement to make and and you
say that we say that because as an
expert Asian expert that's why they
hired him and that's like the worst
possible there is a way to say something
like for example any time like you could
say Stalin killed forty million of his
own people a lot of influence on Russia
Stalin Stalin is he was a monster yes
you can also say that he industrialized
Russia for a lot of reasons it was a
tired and bands we're being paralyzed
but for the most part you don't give a
guy who killed forty million people that
credit and it's the same thing you don't
give you don't excuse Japanese World War
two Japanese aggression they were they
did terrible things and they did
terrible things the Chinese and to the
crayons so he described but every Korean
will tell you that Japan is cultural
technology on the comic economic example
that has been so important to their own
transformation many South Koreans have
used social media to express their anger
including post heated comments yet no
[ __ ] you you owe a formal apology to the
Korean nation for diminishing ridiculing
our painful history during the years of
Japanese colonization many of our
grandfathers
grandmother's were killed by young girls
forced him to be comfort women into
prostitution mr. Ramos is the vice
chairman see Co Co of the Kissinger
associates consulting firm has written
extensively on Asian economics and
politics he knows better he was sloppy
whatever was what you do in the
situation is you apologize well I'll say
I'm very sorry it was possible for him
to do more with us here now it's no
longer possible
ya know buddy yeah you can't yep what
else you choose okay I understand you
know people are very sensitive but
that's that's a reason that's a big one
yeah but you on national I mean crazy
yeah all right there's a bomb discovered
in the Thames River a World War two bomb
it's right next to the airport London
City Airport
yeah how long has it been and since
World War two since 1945 and those bombs
will stay perfectly healthy
they'll just until sure well and it's in
it's in a lake or some [ __ ] it's in
danger Tim's the tackiness Lee yeah so
the river that goes through the famous
river god good luck getting that thing
out it'll take about a day but the whole
all the flights are canceled not bad
though it's just a day about a day it's
spicy Larry James but it's pronounced
Tim hey Larry we didn't need you go down
and get that bomb out today took a real
beating
yikes what else yeah Jim check this side
this is in China Hebei China a gas truck
with liquefied natural gas overturned
and you can see how fast these two cars
I really heard that was a myth like you
know I like with people go you know
there's a gas truck going on the highway
and so and shoots it or it falls over or
propane tanks they explode or that's a
myth well I mean so in this case that
thing overturned and it released and
then cars have engines with that you
know combust fuel there's fire inside
your engine so it just caught on let's
go check out fastest thing goes so and
then this is all bombing you I will stay
in your car yeah but I mean you're gonna
panic at that point we just stayed in
your car and just go backward
so you get the sacred orb drop top and
roll like this question yeah look at all
the cars that's a movie scene oh my god
oh my god that's scary is [ __ ] you know
when I was when I was a young man crazy
it's not a young man I worked at a place
called All Seasons rental and I was in
charge the propane tanks I was in charge
of strapped them to the back of the
truck and make sure they don't fall out
well one day I forgot to strap him up
and we're going on the highway and these
things were dropping like flies out the
back cars were dipping and dodging dip
dodge dick dive hit dodge dodge and and
dip and my brother goes oh my god if one
of those hits the right way it's gonna
explode Wow I got so much trouble didn't
you fire they in so much trouble no
carts hit him no one was hurt nothing
exploded and we talked to the guy like
the propane x-ray guys that really
worked like that is these things of
basically bulletproof man yeah he goes
and that's a spark I like into the tank
but even then there's there's safety
valves for that he goes you're fine it
was it could have killed sone if it
bounced at the windshield as far as
blowing up hills this isn't the movies
Brendan goddamn so I was there went to
think the movie think the movie should
have fired them like that Korean
horrible analysts I should've been fired
well dude that's so scary did the truck
driver die but no there's two draw or
the driver and his passenger they were
severely burned but no one died yeah
well that's a fairly broad really bad
seriously burn it's a bummer yeah what
else you got Jim
so no slow day but there's a guy who
stole a jeep from a woman and this is in
Minnesota smart guy and then I guess the
car broke down somewhere and then this
doesn't tell you how he did it but he
was able to call the owner of the Jeep
and ask her hey listen I just took your
[ __ ] I got a real problem here how do
you turn it back on Brian real quick who
is better here you or him
I did I that is not a very nice thing to
say
I mean Levi got he looks like he feels
sorry though he looks like he's really
sad about what he didn't like things
have not worked out
he is captain rain cloud maybe he's
gonna get here pissed
oh you don't know instead of Ellie go to
your guy he's just Cappy they'd be wet
weird it's Ryan town German Piven go I'm
gonna steal his car and go there oh my
god he's only thirty sad well that's a
problem
you know who's kinda losing my hair hold
on our boy rock called Luke is
definitely is is is following close
behind me
yep yeah you know who's at the office
losing our hair you know I love you Cody
Cody diamond code right here to get a
little light I'll bring that up to him I
see no no he's gonna hurt his feelings
but Cody well he's wearing a hat wearing
a [ __ ] hand goes oh man is lose a
little bit here up there and I saw he's
walking out with Curtis blade through it
oh [ __ ] a little bald on some guy - yeah
propecia ready stop it right away will
it right away I'm on propecia looking
out taking a beautiful my mop is over
the years starting to go away you're not
on probation yeah I've been on propecia
for two years more I know you're helping
hello 51 do you want whatever happened
to the braces I got I supposed to get
fitted for them tomorrow like a
mouthpiece to the podcast
tell him homeboy told me goes dude those
don't work really special guy now that
one your switch for a guy Brian's age
just come from a dentist I don't care
tell him I shut up and I see I made that
up to make my point he just didn't want
me to get [ __ ] shitty brace well no he
got brace to you is I want four months
what these are perfect in and out I'm
gonna wear my Invisalign I mean you're
gonna see me all the time in them no
more I'm not playing around anymore
do you dye your hair Brian or no never
never
this really looks nice yeah leave my
faith God I said I've never dyed my hair
I dye my beard you thought I might be
real guy that beard like a bad guy yeah
I've never dyed my hair ever ever really
that's a good color you know what you're
you you're cause you're here to lose
more how often you touch it
have you ever heard that yeah yeah yeah
when you keep touching your scalp
because you lose more hair really look
at this or it brings because I've heard
the opposite it brings though those are
dead circulation opens dead those are
dead you've killed those I'd have uh I'd
have a little spot burnin up my nose
really not not for cancer just a little
freckle
what's wrong with the front want this
out of here why it's on TV they hide it
with me I know it's a panty has a height
with make I was just stupid [ __ ] like
that as you get older I can't believe
you spot on your spot but then you you
yellow teeth and it's not it's like now
how are you talking about by the way
your teeth are not you're on TV now
let's we got to do something about you
my teeth my teeth look like the mass
compared to you know your teeth I could
bottom teeth be you your very own my
bottom teeth no my bottom round even
yeah I'm oh my god but I'll see your
slave better dear big lips that cover
him but can I be honest with you you
live far small you old front please
there there's an issue going on well I
left my wisdom teeth in so they're
fighting right yeah but fighting I like
your your teeth are very uneven your
teeth are literally like if I had to
drive like a mountain coat would have
trouble no nice try probably really
how's everyone who's ever listening this
show knows you have the worst teeth oh
that's not sure I have good teeth
actually a very good front teeth look
your top right to you Tom others tiny
ones what's a good teeth you're just
yellow very straight they're not that
yellow that's a live it's the lighting
in here your teeth looked like the Hong
Kong skyline now it's crooked and yellow
why'd you have to say Hong Kong and
yellow cuz because the pollution is the
reference no I don't know horrible
pollution not doing our racist rip it up
I don't get any hear tea tastes like a
Beijing skyline oh you said pollution
said yellow yes because their skyline is
yellow cuz all the pollution too many
people alright let's try making this
racist thing alright
well she got Java famine that guys here
line it's awful there's not any good
ones here what about these on do you
know what this one Brian so Robert Wow
who's the old school very very yeah I
want to know why this story keeps
changing wait what happened so Robert
Wagner was 84 years old now this still
looks great
he was a famous TV star in the 70s and
the 80s I'm gonna tell you how everyone
knows him I could be right out us
he's the the guy with the eye patch from
Austin pal yes damn right number two
damn right there you go carry on and oh
that was so Natalie Wood who was a
famous famous movie star the three of
them were on a boat Christopher Walken
Robert Wagner and
would sound she was 40 at the time or
something and gorgeous and she she fell
overboard and you know died dragon yeah
and Christopher Walken and Robert Wagner
were having an argument she the stories
she took a boat and to just get away
from the argument and they were an off
Catalina Island I think is anyone by the
sea and she just died so then no one
they won't open it no one brought up
skeptical it was announced that Ragnar
is not a suspect according to Bureau
statement I mean reopen the collective's
after the conference 2011 this was all
the new brain several new witnesses
statements an information more than 30
years after the drying death of Natalie
Wood for the first time we have
witnesses statements to portray a new
series of events on the boat that night
so it's possible that he could have done
it on purpose and well more that was
that was his girl or they got it they
were had they had an argument so he
might have hit her and she fell over her
died you know witness probably details
about the hearing hearing yellow yelling
and crashing sounds covering a couple
stateroom okay so they're fighting
shortly afterwards separate witnesses
identified a man and a woman arguing on
the back of the boat the witness
believed that the voices belong to
Natalie wooden Robert Wagner however not
all of the witness accounts a line with
what the bureau previously heard as you
may recall Natalie Wood was later
reported missing from the boat yeah I
don't know man do we have enough to make
the arrest at this moment no there's she
might have been drunk she went I got
into the boat fallen overboard she got a
dinghy they did you know
yikes yeah I don't know I don't know you
never will know no but over 30 years
later case back open he's a person of
interest now he's not he's not as been
labeled two person injuries in the case
not a suspect 30 years later good luck
with that
I'll watch Cold Case Files B what's up
with your spin-off we get any news any
update they're just talking about it now
and ABC the head the execs now make a
decision yeah does anyone when you talk
to your agents for manners don't want to
give you a timeline oh no my feeling
obvious things is it's timing you could
get picked up next year you can pick up
later this year do you think if it gets
picked up I can
can see it getting picked up for six
over the summer or something like I
could see that happening you know I mean
cuz it's the last season of Goldberg
correct yeah if you have 18 and I don't
know there's one more season one more
one more season so to a night - yeah so
you know I don't know I don't know they
did you know me I don't I don't I don't
think you'll talk about it there's
nothing you do can I haven't thought
about it once when you brought her up I
just thought about it seriously it's so
funny how me sorry I'd like an update
yeah no it's good but I'm nothing
nothing they had a good meeting I know
that at ABC quote-unquote a good meeting
whatever that means
yeah because they have to recast me
along I think because she's doing CSI
now I have you know I love Dabney on it
but she's amazing
yeah we'll see well you will see it all
right come see me in Arizona this
weekend who lover bird well this
Wednesday this Wednesday lover bird
Phoenix live third Thursday Friday
Saturday
nothing gets Valentine's starred like
the old Brad Brad
that's right that's right ladies and
gentlemen Valentine's Day get your girl
chocolate-covered strawberries in a dick
joke brightly cute Carolyn I will I'm
Cupid I'm a funny Cupid everybody Oh
Cupid I'll bring you picking red hot I'm
Pierre yeah the love meter hits red hot
with Bryan Callen Jimmy stage at the
improv and next week I am at the Comedy
Store in La Jolla
Friday Saturday only two shows Friday to
show Saturday you teeth right now t fat
K calm Vancouver I love you guys but we
are not headed there we are rescheduling
that don't hate me we will be back trust
that I will take care of you guys we
love Ann Cooper and March I'm in Tampa
Palm Beach in Orlando in Orlando Tampa
both almost sold out get your tickets
now for Palm Beach Deepak a calm for
Brian and myself hey February 28th and
just so you know I got my showcase for
some bigwigs at the Melrose improv so
you need people to come out yeah lock
February 28th key
to Melrose improv yeah it's gonna be
good I'm bringing heat get him this is
the fight of the kid we're out